so what have I done down here you can
see we've evaluated now you might notice
I've not even gotten the numbers the
final answer at the bottom because when
you look at this you can think Oh
without even evaluating the next line
this is clearly not zero right and
that's the only number I'm searching for
you're like with these negatives they're
huge when you look at something like
this it's a little less obvious but
because you've only got two alternatives
you can go ahead you can verify in your
calculator this is zero bless you okay
now at this point here what you could do
is you could go to the factor theorem
again to try and find the rest of the
factors that's what the factor theorem
is for after all but there's a quicker
and stickier way we can do this okay we
don't need to right think about this
what we've found is that there's a
double root at negative seven so when we
look at our original polynomial right I
can rewrite it as well if something has
a double root at negative seven
then what thing can I write in the
factorization hold on hold on x plus
seven like this guy right X plus seven
and it has to be squared that's what
makes it a double root okay and then
there's going to be something else
hanging on the end okay now I don't know
what that is yet I have some very good
guesses but I don't want to just guess
and then see what happens
so because I don't know what it is yet
I'm just going to call it alpha where
the other root is alpha okay now watch
this this is so charming it's just
really nice to see how it works right I
know that my polynomial will eventually
look like this once it's all done
agustin right but I already know before
it's all factorize that it's equal to
this right so what I can do is I can
just choose a convenient value of x this
requires a little bit of creativity
I can choose a convenient value of x to
put into here that makes an alpha easy
to see right now
essentially what I want to do is just
get alpha by itself right that would be
nice and then I can solve this whole
thing so I'm going to choose I'm going
to let X equal
zero if I let X equal zero then over
here in that little set of brackets all
you get is just the what - and the Alpha
all by itself okay so watch what happens
I'm gonna let X equal zero so I get P of
0 equals what what's gonna start right
on the right-hand side have a look hold
on I've got it I've got to put 0
everywhere I saw Rex before right so
I've got zero plus seven I'm just gonna
do the substitution step squared and
then I've got so you're myself alpha
very good but from the very first line I
know what P of X is and if I put in P of
0 into here what happens to all of these
terms they all vanish right 0 cubed 0 0
squared 0 etc all you get left with it's
this guy on the end here right so I'm
gonna have negative 245 is that okay
that's what happened when I substituted
zero it what's this equal to 49 and then
of course you've just got negative alpha
here right is that all right and now you
can see if all I want is alpha what
should i divide both sides by yeah
probably the negative as well and when
you divide that by a negative 49
surprise surprise you get five no long
division required you get a forty right
here yep so what Rasmus suggesting is
sort of slotting in at this line here
and say you'd get x squared what would
be the rest of that when you expand the
expo several square 14x plus 49 which is
true and then you've got the X minus
alpha it's still hanging on there so
what you can say is I can what we call
this is comparing coefficients so if I
compare the constant coefficient over
here which is negative 245 it must be
equal to the constant coefficient over
here which would be negative for you an
alpha but that's exactly what I end up
with here so essentially yes we can but
because that's the same thing that we've
got here all right so as my final line
I can say therefore is because alpha is
not what I was searching for my original
question was factorized right so I can
finish the factorization I had most of
it there didn't I X plus 7 or squared
and then X minus 5 tons keys so it takes
a bit more thinking but actually much
less working if you end up cleverly
using some of your facts about calculus
and double roots okay to sit on every
questions on this were there any point
at which you're like nah I missed the
leap of logic it was a bit confusing